how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all but how
that I guess in dog
but can I add one which is that I think
you have a an interest and I'd like to
hear you talk about it in explaining why
it is that we are living at a moment
where we seem to be increasingly tribal
first of all I'm sorry with my love for
this paper everything on this panel I
really think that the word tribal yes is
a distraction from very important issues
migrant citizenship visa that these are
very important concepts you know it's
very often our prejudices and our powers
very often are the hegemonies as well as
our resistance comes from being citizens
and you know your apps you're right that
that you're think that there are no
borderless that nations have borders but
of course many people who move like you
and me move because we want to belong
somewhere else where we feel more
productive for whatever reason doesn't
mean I don't adore BOM Baird or Bombay
to death but it it does mean that I
moved first to England and then to the
States so let us respect the fact that
each time we move there is a nation
state there is a community which we feel
serves us better so let's not be
embarrassed about that and I think that
citizenship rather than tribalism is the
important way to go let me just say that
there is one way of thinking about
opening up the nation do the issues of
migration to the issues of global
inequality which is to think of the past
in the present to think that known that
most nations were constructed and John
Stuart Mill is of course the the master
of this moment were constructed when
empires were being constituted so when
we think about cosmopolitanism today
when we think about the hospitality to
the migrant and we have to think not in
individual terms we also have to think
in institutional terms when we think of
contemporary notions of nationhood then
and all cosmopolitanism we have to be
able to think about the pasts upon which
the nation-state was built you know John
Stuart Mill says somewhere I am
Democrat in my country and I'm a despot
in somebody else's country what does
that make of me and I think that's the
question that Trump that's the question
that Modi that's the question that most
of the tribal nationalist donation face
we are constructed in this problem and
unless we see that contradiction we're
not going to go anywhere so when we
think about them and us that then is the
us the migrants of the people who come
post Colonials who come and settle for
required demand respect demand a certain
security because they don't get it they
also belong to a history a long history
of the modern world which was a history
of slavery and civility colonialism
barbarism and civility why can we not
face the fact that the Enlightenment as
we understand it all liberalism was
constituted from this and I think if we
see that internal session or internal
confrontation it's not a pregnant a shoe
we can actually become much truer
citizens to ourselves in the nations
which we do which we belong to and much
truer in our hospitality and
understanding of conditions across the
world and the EMU interdependencies let
us not forget the globalization may
create technological connectivity but
globalization has constructed its own
forms of poverty inequality so it's not
as if these inequalities are only left
over from the concept of the Westphalian
state B there are new forms of
inequality that have been constructed
through the global so it seems to me
that some form of enlightened
cosmopolitanism that understands that
the history of nations is also the
history of slavery also those to
colonize a cube and that the peoples
from elsewhere
foreigners are part of that long history
and it is our responsibility to create a
democratic structure in the great form
of cosmopolitan conversation
intersecting with our national sense
about belonging and to actually only
through that way can we move forward and
I'm convinced that that is very
important get your tickets for the
world's largest music and philosophy
festival how the light gets in
dog